malaria gorgeous wildly imaginative
dumber than a bag of hammers I'd like to
say hey I can say I loved it I like it I
like it this movies even though it's the
dumbest fucking thing she didn't know
what every criticism you have heard is
correct yeah a lot of criticism I've
heard that wasn't grant intent I found
new criticisms then I am yeah and
there's something that is behind any
read about so friggin stupid but I think
it's why when we came out as we both had
the exact same thought people watching
us a probably fans of Mystery Science
Theater and with if you've seen the new
one you been - yes okay so I came yeah I
came out this film our dad saw - and I
turned him on the way out done was well
ahead of me I said you know what this
was this was star grass was a 100
something million dollar budget yeah my
dad's like yeah that's right you 20
minutes later come up to be you know
what's roblem like what that was Star
Trek yeah like see here's the thing you
cannot go into this movie thinking
you're gonna see a good movie going yeah
go into this movie thinking I'm gonna
see hilarious space trash just stupid
nonsense yeah and I mean on a level far
below mm v element like just Shakespeare
yeah okay and here's the thing we should
make clear uh what we thought this
element cuz a lot of people are like
listen it's like a sequel no it's not a
sequel but the same people and it's yeah
I know what that element was inspired by
and v elements the better movie I acted
a better movie I love this element but
okay it's fucking stupid stupidness
elements dumb too but this L there is
someone rounded there no but somewhere
somebody you know like the this mindset
came in oh yes this is a classic this is
a masterpiece pith helmet I know it it's
stupid but I didn't say like imaginative
anyway start okay episode 4 a new hope
it's got a lot of dominant but I still
considered a masterpiece it's like that
it's like okay this is silly dumb space
opera fun like but it's still well but I
mean and why are why are you doing this
at the moment no no no cuz I looked at
but somewhere people just put on this
like huge pedestal and I'm just like
okay no look this world is phenomenal I
would even argue this world is even more
phenomenal you know then when there's
kind of a trade so this world has like
we're in fifth Helmand you get about
five or six really amazing worlds this
has like dozens of amazing worlds
amazing creatures they are everywhere
you can watch it a million times and
nothing so many humans and these average
no no no I I daren't you do see a lot of
these worlds a lot of these aliens and
creatures I want know more about them
and stuff but here's the thing this
element has very likable goofy but very
likable charming main characters uh this
one they're likable in a different way
in that way are they're awful so awful
and a lot of that sadly is the acting
okay but it is so what I can to make
okay and you know comedians ripoff
material from other comedians and other
sources and I'm not going to do that
here so I'm going to give credit where
all creditors dude so it's an art critic
friend who works at Roger Ebert matte
figure home this is for you he texted us
and said valerian is what would happen
if you gave made that Legend of Zelda
animated cartoon from the super mario
super show a live-action movie that's
pretty much in a space and once he said
that and once i sat there watched it I
could not unsee it to the point that
every line this kid says and every line
that that girl says just were making me
laugh because any second I was expecting
an excuse me
sergeants or everything I say or love me
here this to make it funnier this kid
the girl about half the time I could
take seriously the other half she's
super flat but this kid if they're davis
be the the serious foil does like why
are we doing it like their shit like
this boy has the phobias Keanu Reeves
voice and I'm knocking about now piano
is like I finally got kind of used to
Keanu Reeves noise but it's not some bit
of Bill and Ted Kim yeah
only Bill and Ted trying to down top
this is Bill and Ted trying to sound
like John wick I'm totally I'm like
totally going to like eggs you in the
face every toss me your doctorate lap
young another fajitas having a bath mine
yeah we just going up now it's not only
it's not only Keanu Reeves II's ascended
level above Keanu Reeves he is the key
ah no he is the Keanu Reeves spoof in
kung fury go watch it on that play I
know I'm but well like literally
everything he said of reminding me of
Convergys hacker man the greatest hack
around the planet like in everything he
says is just super serious yes did you
know him you know him yeah so it is it
end okay you know if you go in think
you're gonna see a good movie you're not
you're in my world of hurt yeah I guess
you so any knowing it's bad I think
you're gonna have a great yeah and I
think a lot of people are guys don't
remember out this element before it's
because I think like a lot of people are
they oh this element was so much higher
and I do like this element better but
third guy Dan says that people go and
say what we're going to see something
really good and really groundbreaking
really like oh I thought it's going to
be like fifth element it's his element
is still pretty but it does not have the
bearer varicella very yet there is a
major differences here one fifth element
had more practical effects the CGI in
this some of its very good some of it is
laugh-out-loud funny like others
everywhere but yeah I'm sure like some
of it had awful and some of its really
really good but there's like no but it's
an inconsistent like there's some shots
on look at elements Oh baby fair but
there was more of a reliance on
practical effects in favela windows
there what if Elmo was a good mix um the
other thing is is filmmakers element was
going better paced and it was funnier
hmm this one is not as this one is very
funny but it's unintentionally they they
are like obvious yeah it's just his line
reads arts like I'm sure people ready to
kill me cuz I was laughing every time he
opened his mouth or he would he would
squint his eyes and do this thing like
thinking of snow I just look at Venice
in I was just laughing I can't do this
yeah yeah when I finally just accepted
it except of the crazy eyes of lightning
okay as long as a weird nirvana of right
the first few lines he had I'm laughing
my ass off like this is the most amazing
performance I've ever seen
dunk it's like this is I can't do this
like buddy and if it dubt got Stockholm
Syndrome was like I have identity as my
god time y'all you a minute it's every
two minutes to stop worrying and love
the bomb yeah no I love him in this but
it is not good I like if the Tommy was
so quality yeah a lot of the other
actors kind of do the Fifth Element over
the top particular like that I in the
marketplace really yeah or just be sure
to put on your I love that guy oh you
ready have you lie you is the Chris
element and there's these three little
aliens that all talk headed oh they are
not advancing in the myung fields
there's a lot of those moans see I
thought this whole movie was going to be
super super dull super super boring and
take yourself too seriously but it is
still goofy and it is still my problem
it was when it tries to be taken
seriously in the mail so hard that
hilarious me it was super super fun
super super wildly imaginative and then
loses all that somewhere after the
halfway point I think I'm in the lab
yeah there's like a kind of thing with
the fifth element this element goes a
little sail after they leave the cruise
buddy shorter path is a shorter yeah
this one just lingers um you had chopped
30 minutes yeah that was a big value
question but I love the guy yeah you
just need to chop 30 minutes and the
last part you know there's a sequence
that is way too phantom entity for me
right we're underwater yeah I think
where's Jar Jar um
the scene with where they're feeding the
big
emperor dude I actually like that no no
but how I got there was just made no
sense
honestly the majority of this movie in
terms of time to a story if you can cut
it all sideways but then all in it's
Legend of Zelda it's all about the side
quest but they're just always retaining
there's this great joke involving the
Hat
the main girl is wearing and it's just
beautifully built up to an umbrella
Amidala color so funny it's such a great
payoff and I'm like okay know this I
felt like this is Luke I have similar
problems that Jupiter ascending heads
but it has a good sense of where a
better mood it more fun it's like even
when it's bad if they're attained
Jupiter ascending when it's bad with the
exception of any red may say so every
way that's a good way of putting it
though take Jupiter ascending and remove
the self seriousness of it yeah and like
that's probably close to this and it's
more entertaining like just straight up
but there are problems I focus on yeah
those three dudes though the law
Howard's a nice finish yeah no I said
it's like what would happen if you took
Huey Dewey and Louie and put them in
that machine from the fly look to me or
like give Howard the dust with a meth
addict yeah
no I'm the other three were great it's
it's super okay my problem of the film
is it's super wildly imaginative like
I'm like okay there should I haven't
seen but there was an over reliance on
CGI where it's so unnecessary I'm like
really the guy who gave us for some of
the good it he gave us the diva singing
and I thought it was a cool costume this
one is essentially the same characters
it's these Avatar ripoffs and I'm like
why are they CGI you could have done
this without a guy hired super tall thin
super models and there you go and here's
my problem I was bringing this up okay
and it's really not a jesting so your
total not aliens as I just must be aware
this is so great well then stuff like
that how come every single body type of
these things looks exactly the same do
they never eat more are any born shorter
or any lower or when you're away it's by
reason they are all exactly the same but
all these aliens look alike to know it
is a cup know the face of surprise a
little different all the bodies look
exactly the same II didn't think of that
only thing about the effect the only
thing was the lips somehow the lips I
bought everything else about charging
iron iron and then hold is beautiful I
mean it's highly magic I'm not again
I am in that screensaver for him yeah
that's think this is literally
deviantART desktops of the movie but
okay what yeah and it's gorgeous
I am I did really I'll share with that I
wish that like he put more practical
effect in with the CG because there are
moments where there are guys in suits
they're robots in real suits they're
really there yeah there's some real a
bit up yeah they have scene where the
aliens are all talking in the council
room they're all really there I'm like
and you can tell it sticks out like a
sore thumb because it's practical
fucking effects and I get if you want to
use CGI sometime that and the set and
the world yeah be cgi yeah some of the
CG on the longshots is great like but
but I'm just like if you can put people
into make up them what the fuck are you
doing here with this like particularly
Luke Poisson who made like some cool
practical effects for the other movie so
there's that bothered me so this movie
is getting a ton of hate even from the
people we saw it with my dad who pith
helmet is his favorite movie and hey all
this was so boring I couldn't get into
himself I agree it excitement factor of
meat-eaters out somewhere in the way 30
yeah that's where cuz I might read
letter the first half a lot I don't read
fun in a granny don't like any of it I
know what they're talking about I know
what people that just like to talk about
but again I was going in with the idea
that this was going to be a dumb bad
movie and I got that it was entertaining
lead um is entertainingly bad until
again about the last third and now I'm
like okay we need to wrap it up yeah we
you know evil man taking over the native
okay it was on it was on a that's the
point the only points were bothered me
like it was unimaginative when they went
underwater and I'm like okay I saw this
in the Phantom Menace
yeah maybe it's in the graphic novel
what we have to do it is in the grand
because but I'm like that's what I'm you
don't know anything abut maybe Lucas
ripped it also the Valyrian graphic no
but the point is we've seen it on screen
already so come up with something better
um some bad Doug changes by their if you
watch their list there's a lot of times
where it's like okay that's not what
they said that's not the voices even
like the weird avatar alien visit this
is our Emperor Emperor so-and-so man
with his life and stuff like thank you
sir
hello how are you clearly a woman voice
and I'm just like there are other ones
that have like male voice that houses
it's not a female body or I think just
how just identifies but you have a kid
did you adopt a Jim it's like even in
their own world or sort of these things
that don't add up and make sense and
there can be a little distracted all it
was really good like I'm just like okay
I haven't seen this before like I would
honestly see this again uh you know even
my minor no I would I was signing one to
like fit fit yeah no no no I was but
with the password button there okay okay
on the small screen I see you I'm not
sure I would see it on the big screen I
wish I could I wish I would sit through
the first two thirds of it again this
would not be even go watch the rest of
Dunkirk yeah no this was not showing it
I max I think Dunkirk probably had that
and it's one of those where my wife
leaned over and said it was a pimple and
I've actually been really nice and no
like that was but I would have loved her
out because hers was so good and I man
no I know I saw dunk I'm sure it is
everything you haven't yeah I got the a
spill and I got a see John Kirk is good
and Kirk eight went surprisingly really
good at this I knew I want to see on the
big screen size is this cat so tough and
we both saw baby driving like that so
yeah honestly this is probably the least
of everything I've seen but I'm still
like no fun like it's a pretty good
summer so far I might blown away by what
a great summer yeah you bet it really
does but not not me I'm here to believe
in have a good DC film I wear what we're
doing very good
oh wait for it just as we yeah sure
well that that's not sober though it's
okay yeah Oh God for that well but no
even this one this one that's getting
you know pretty panned by people I'm
like this is still just AI mind-blowing
ly imaginative and and fun and
adventurous answer you just watched it
on mute you could get some great yeah
it's like watching a Mystery Science
Theater movie I know some people that
don't like mystery signs either even
with the guys commenting there's like I
just feel like the IV's family get it
yeah and it's kind of like that's like
if you're not into that kind of bad
Tulloch sighs i then you're not like
you're just not going to get anything
out of it so I get that I will say this
though
like the people were just like her
McGirt it's sitting at 60% and written
two million it
okay fifty cents whatever I'm like do
they remember what the reviews were when
Fifth Element came out the one Weber
beer as a class yeah I sitting at 70% of
Ron tomatoes and that after people have
come around like oh no actually it's
probably a really decent movie no this
is that did not wait you reduce overtime
it did not he got very mixed reviews
from a movie yeah I can't act like I
don't get that even though I hugely
enjoyed fifth element it's like but it
is real to bed when I development the
first time I didn't know what to make of
it like you you I think you liked it I
know a dad like this I was just because
we were in high school that I know it's
yeah I should have a look that was like
I don't know if I like that I think I
did I mean I guess I had fun like it
wasn't until it came out of DVD and I
started watching it then I'm like oh
this is a really really good movie now I
have no idea maybe that will not happen
on this movie will only get worse I will
say this movie to me already looks dated
on a rising Evo 8 dated on arrival a
figure at work I I can almost assure you
this is gonna get a fifth element when I
saw it a couple held up I'm like I'm
amazed at how this movie could still be
released today and most and for the most
part work not like it's dated this one
with the CGI some of it is so good but
there are other scenes I'm like this
already looks dated like this came out
10 years ago plan to be fair so might
fit like okay no you ho / - rating okay
but again your money and I want to sell
guys say you have yet know exactly you
have like yeah six worlds maybe infidel
me you have something like 12 here I
mean it's to spread god you got so many
worlds and so the thing is like here's
world yeah much I'm like again I'm like
oh my wife pointed this out and I
thought the same thing she's like my
only thing is they did this whole like
chichi thing at the beginning where it's
is like these aliens do nice things to
me really do you think these aliens are
cool they're underwater and it's just
like oh cool I guess these they're all
going to participate oh we're going to
see them we're going to go to these well
no you just never seen them again
mmm then there was the one guy who's the
voice by John was like I will find you I
will find you and I'm a hunch of John
DeLorean through the galaxies I will
burn
or just a ten-minute chasey yeah and
then you never is ready at Icarus I'm
like what was the point of that they're
like oh there's no there's tons of
things like that no but what I pointed
out is that there's a scene where it's
like both the main characters spend a
good 10 20 minutes like one is where
she's saving him as an art way miss is
been saving her and it's like both are
pretty pointless but it's like okay you
see these different worlds and stuff but
there's one see where it's like you know
if it's these alien fishing it's he's
butterflies and she grabs one and holds
her up and she's fun too full wooden
cage and taken out and stuff like that
so he's like oh no I'm not gonna say hot
and you know so he grabs a butterfly go
dude and they reel them up it goes a
little gun my baton
let me change I go oh yes it is very
much like just random just like I'm a
strong female character except when I'm
not and easily I understand and and love
you and I'm the best agent on the planet
except when I'm not know like it this is
Barry yeah I don't know my favorite his
mummy says I'm gonna hunt you down to
the very end of time except when I don't
know my favorite alien little things
except when you don't see it up again
but it's a favorite at the end I try not
to laugh is when they have like a
decision agent no you don't get it
I'm by the book I always follow the
rules rule to be broken how many
different ways did you find us
no I it's great like we like this book
yeah but that's good endings not good
its charm if it's like the room it's
charming that it's kind of yeah yeah
very imagine I had a good time really I
will yell you have too long in other
cuts what if it did sound to you like
just like while they're going to waste
my time on track like that then don't
lie I'm not good if you're looking for
things that not like about you will find
point if you're the type it's like well
I could see us winning work about my
danke or I could sit through valerian
like just see Dunkirk tobacco your dad
every time you see a my mother it's a
better fit Hotel concurrence amazing
apes is amazed h-honestly I still think
it's probably the better film even
kirk so i I don't know it's we're like
fancy a monkey moves the best thing I've
seen all year so if this is really one
of those do you want to check your brain
throw it out go and enjoy some visuals
and laugh at how stupid the get up your
thing etherion is I that's what it was
for me and I know literally I'll get it
literally in marijuana the movie yeah go
there you get bait you're like I want
popcorn and then you laugh at the most
ridiculous silly things and odds are
you're going to be the only one laughing
in the cinema like yeah cuz other people
are in on the joke except for that one
guy who's sitting out behind us yeah
doesn't know my parrot so they'd a had a
trail anyway I'm like two minutes okay
it's a very cool gonna turn pitch
perfect 3 which looks terrible and I
actually like the first one but and then
one line she has is like well like I'm
Felicity I'm dozens like what like if
you include me like I could be obesity
way in the back I just they're like this
laughs I was like oh my god like I guess
he liked that joke and then yeah like
random moments in the middle of this
movie just I hope we weren't laughing
like that yeah we weren't no I would
snickering because any time he opened
his lips so we have to do this to
complete action I don't know I was so we
yeah I was laughing like oh we had a
blast down we can't guarantee if you
will it's tough
I'm not gonna lie but uh oh you go run
run tomatoes does not surprise me
no so because you love this movie be
kind of people don't I guess they're
coming from if you hated this movie be
kind of people I got to enjoyed it
anyway because I will get a following
but it will not be as big as like a hell
my youtube ability following it I want
to say AB star Crashers dark red yeah
yeah yeah I think people really find
entertaining like but definitely I think
this will become with those goofy cult
movies yeah I can't see how it can y'all
not achieve that closer to Master P
status like no no no oh that car take we
have like a minute of battery left so
we'll see you guys next night Mike I'm
allergic to Center escape
you